There is a certain natural phenomenon
that you may or may not be familiar
with,
a facial expression made by the human
when one of its number is holding and
reading a book.
The head is slightly raised,
turned at 20 to 30 degrees from the
forward eyes widen slowly.
Pupils dilate.
Vision enhances this,
followed by a momentary paralysis in
which a number of subjects have recorded
a feeling of quote,
loveliness.
Here it is in its closest approximation,
and here are some of the commonly sited
causes.
What is that feeling when you're driving
away from people and they recede on the
plane till you see their specs
dispersing.
It's the two huge world vaulting us and
it's goodbye,
but we lean forward to the next crazy
venture beneath the skies for a moment
of phrase,
tried to take shape in my mouth and my
lips parted like a dumb man's as though
there was more struggling upon them than
a wisp of startled air,
but they made no sound and what I had
almost remembered was incommunicable
forever.
A solemn consideration.
When I enter a great city by night that
every one of those darkly clustered
houses in closes its own secret that
every room and every one of them
encloses it's own secret,
that every beating heart in the hundreds
of thousands of breasts there is in some
of it's imagining,
so secret to the heart,
nearest it.
There are more things in heaven and
earth,
Horatio than are dreamt of in your
philosophy.
Maybe you know the feeling and if you
do,
you could like I did produce a list of
quotes that triggers the same natural
phenomenon in you and knowing that you
know that these words don't just knock
us around intellectually,
but physically they twist us into knots
or untie the tightest ones within us.
They put us face to face with our
illusions are bigotries our
preconceptions.
You know that to grasp just one sentence
of the very best writing is to grasp a
thousand sentences of great writing,
which is to grasp 10,000
sentences of good.
Right?
And in this way,
great books are very expensive things.
They come at the cost of thousands and
thousands of sentences.
They come at the cost of dozens of
easier books and children's books and
picture books and simple poems and sing
along songs.
They come at the cost of a room to read
room to read,
promotes literacy around the world by
building libraries and getting kids
access to books,
helping millions to put their very first
down payments on dickens or Shakespeare.
This is a phenomenon we should help
everyone to feel
right.